it's great to be joined today by Chris
Bailey who is the author of two books
about productivity which have been
published in 13 languages hyper-focus
how to be more productive in a world of
distraction and the productivity project
so Chris first of all thanks for talking
to me about this yeah thanks for having
me man
so first place I want to start before we
get into some of the more specifics is
that I find the whole productivity field
interesting because on the one hand for
a long time I've been delving into such
questions as when in the day am I most
productive what techniques were
organizing my work would be important to
achieve maximum productivity sort of the
nitty-gritty of it and yet at the same
time Chris I am concerned at the more
social level about the focus on more
productivity all the time because I
believe that not being productive in a
sort of deliberate and thoughtful way is
a really important thing for humans to
sort of be doing for our health
so the question one is how do we kind of
square those two sides yeah like what's
the point of productivity like that this
is an idea that I've struggled with
personally because the very idea that
you want to become more productive
implies on some level that you're not
entirely satisfied with where you're at
already but we're at where I like to go
is what strives at what what drives me
to become more productive and ultimately
I'm a very lazy person I like to veg out
I like to read books in my spare time I
don't like to you know just work all the
time and so I think everybody comes to
productivity for a different reason but
I think the best reason to strive to
become more productive is so that we can
make more time for what's actually
meaningful to us in our spare time and
that the idea of productivity like it's
such a loaded term I find like what
comes to mind for a lot of people is
something that feels so cold and
corporate and all about this mindless
efficiency but I think it's something
that makes us more human because when
we're perfectly productive we accomplish
more of what we set out to while we
carve out more time for doing what we
want so I think like you hit the nail on
the head
it's so critical to have a good reason
for wanting to become more productive as
opposed to just wanting to do more more
MORE faster faster faster because that
just leads you to spend more time on
autopilot mode and not really accomplish
what's important in your life yeah and
here in the US it's become almost
fetishized like that is so busy right if
you if you're not busy there almost got
to be judgements made as to what what
exactly is it that you're doing and it
seems that that's the sort of ugly side
of productivity the good one is the one
we're about to talk about but the ugly
side for me is the sort of becoming the
the ideal becoming to be so busy that
you have no time for friends or family
or relaxation and that do you how do you
when people come to you and they say
listen I want to be more productive
here's the list of a hundred things I
need to be fitting in how do you sort of
broach the idea that it might be
important to think about busyness and
productivity is two different things
like is that an idea yeah well yeah like
and I make the argument in hyper focus
that we've never been so busy while
accomplishing so little and productivity
it's not about how much we produce it's
about how much we accomplish over the
course of the day that's what we're left
with that that's what's different in the
world because we lived or worked a day
of our life and so do you produce you
know 100 emails and not accomplish a
single thing all day or do you actually
do things that progress your work
forward and so I find that you know when
when somebody says I'm so busy David
like it's essentially just a way for me
to say I'm so important and the world
needs me so much that it's asking for so
much for me and I'm so busy I can't fit
in anything you know the biggest be
s-saying in the world is I don't have
time for that you know people say I
don't have time to to read a book for
example people have the time they just
spend it watching TV or on Instagram or
social media or vegging out on Netflix
you know it's so often we when we say we
don't have the time for something and
we're so busy it's we we have the
we just spend it on other things and so
it's really like so much of productivity
in this way is about taking that step
back from what we're doing in the first
place so we can see a what's important
but B what we should be focusing on in
the first place so we have that
intention behind what we're doing and
you know if there's one thing that I
found in all this research by the way I
came at this topic from the opposite
direction wanting to do more more more
faster faster faster but the more I
explore about productivity the more I
realize it's not about doing more faster
it's about doing the right things and
doing those things with intention and I
like to focus a lot on attention on how
we focus because it's it's the most
limited ingredient we have to to
becoming more productive and when we
focus without intention behind what
we're doing it's essentially just wasted
energy and so you know that that's what
I'd say to that is that intention it has
to lie at the core of of everything we
do are there any universal truths about
productivity or is it really it depends
on the person and what I'm sort of
getting at is in this book when Daniel
pink talks about how great there are
night owls there are people who work
better sort of naturally in the morning
or middle and there's a sort of the this
idea sometimes that you get your best
work done in the morning but it doesn't
really seem to be true for everybody so
are there any Universal productivity or
efficiency ideas that you find hold true
for everybody there are but there are
very few you know that this is personal
productivity it's not economic
productivity for example and so it's
personal everybody's wired differently
everybody does different work everybody
chooses different things the different
productivity strategies that resonate
with them more strongly what what bucks
me more than anything in this
productivity space you know I've been
fortunate that I'm kind of like one step
removed from the productivity space I
like to filter out the research and the
advice that other people are giving and
call BS on the stuff that that is BS and
whenever somebody says like I have this
five this ten step system for getting
more done every day I immediately start
to question that person's that advice
because you know there are some general
truths like the things that contribute
to our productivity is one of them like
we need energy to be to burn in order to
be productive we need to be deliberate
about how we focus or else the world
will take control over our attention as
opposed to us but but the ways when we
need to manage our time as well
obviously but the ways by which we go
about doing those things and focusing
deeper and and harnessing how much
energy we have and managing our time are
different for everybody so this is
something that I like to encourage in my
books is take what works for you and
leave the rest because there's a lot of
BS out there and you should be
questioning questioning at all what
seems to be the right use of caffeine
within the space that we're talking
about Cheers
IIIi view caffeine and alcohol as
similar constructs you know caffeine is
a way by which we can summon some energy
from later on in the day to use now and
so for hunkering down on like an
important conversation like this one if
we're hunkering down on writing
something important or an important
meeting we can use that energy boost for
greater productivity because we can have
more of us to give to to what we're
doing in a moment and caffeine kind of
narrows our attentional spotlight in on
doing one important thing at a time
and so you know we have to use that
boost wisely though because later on in
the day our energy you might experience
as if you caffeinate to to higher levels
your energy dips a little bit and and so
you might you know instead of using that
energy boost first thing in the morning
so you have more energy to go about your
daily ritual and reading the paper and
the news maybe use it when you're just
getting to work and so you can actually
benefit from that I view alcohol in a
similar way as a way by which we borrow
energy as well as happiness from the
following day and so we you know we we
get to have a looser experience today at
the price of a worse one tomorrow but it
actually you know it alcohol has been
served has been shown to make our
attention
inhibited well caffeine makes our
attention more inhibit so it makes ideas
more free-flowing and so maybe if you're
brainstorming at night having a glass of
wine with your you know your notepad
that you're scribbling on is a helpful
thing to do but God help you if you need
to focus after that point in terms of
the tasks that somebody might do
throughout the day I've experimented
with number one getting directly into
the ones the tasks that are either the
more complex ones or the ones I kind of
don't really feel like doing first to
feel like I have the most sort of
annoying stuff out of the way
I've also experimented with getting to
sort of the simpler easier tasks first
to start crossing a bunch of stuff off
of my to-do list the sort of small wins
approach get a bunch of small wins
earlier in the day do you have feelings
one way or the other about that no I
don't and this is one of those things
where you got a you know we all have so
much data at our disposal we just need
to look back at our own life and this is
I think one of the frustrating things
that that interviews violent when
chatting with me is like productivity is
personal like I offer up a bunch of
suggestions in my books and stuff like
that but you know IIIi personally find
that that easing into the day is is more
effective for me but then again I have
more energy later on in the day I
struggle to get through the mornings and
so I would if I were to offer up one
suggestion with regard to that I would
say you know like what Dan pink says it
in his book when line up when you do
your most productive and ugliest tasks
with when you have the most energy and
so if you have if you like having a cup
of coffee in the morning and in the
morning you're one of these people these
weirdos who spring out of bed are you
one of these people man basically yeah I
mean like within Tom oh geez I it takes
me like a few hours to ease into the day
I'm still what is it I don't have my
watch on but it's like 10:00 a.m. and
I'm still easing into the day but but
then again like I'm cranking out work at
1:00 in the morning and so I would say
align it with when you have the greatest
amount of energy do the ugliest tasks
then you know the things that lead us to
procrastinate
are fascinating that there are certain
attributes that a task can have that
make us more likely to put it off
whether task is boring whether it's
frustrating
whether it's difficult whether it's
ambiguous whether it is unstructured and
the more of these attributes that a task
has the more likely we are to put it off
for for another day and so if you find
that you have a lot of tasks like these
you know align those for when you have
the most energy maybe reward yourself
with a cup of coffee
you know our attention is fascinating
it's drawn like a magnet to anything
that we find pleasurable in the moment
to anything we find threatening in the
moment and to anything we find new and
novel in the moment and so if you look
at how technology companies structure
their apps and their devices your
smartphone for example it's probably the
most pleasurable threatening and novel
thing on the planet it's unlike it's
pretty much the opposite of the uglier
tasks on your plate and so you know part
of it is is aligning them 20 of the most
energy but part of it also is getting
rid of these distractions so you can
carve out the room in which to focus
more deeply last thing I want to touch
on in the limited time we have is this
entire movement and milieu around
productivity basically a middle class
and higher thing in the West in other
words if you're doing shift work at a
factory the type of stuff you and I are
talking about and that you write about
doesn't really apply to you or is there
a way in which it does the the
distinction I think it largely is and
you know that that's an idea that I'd
have to incubate a bit more but the main
separation that I've found in my work is
that that when somebody does knowledge
work for a living you know they're
they're are a programmer they're they're
a writer they're they are a code or
whatever might be versus a factory
worker there is very little room for a
factory worker to become more productive
you know if you crank out eleven widgets
instead of ten you're ten percent more
productive over the course of the day
but if you're a programmer for example
or somebody who who does knowledge work
for a living
you can crank out four hundred lines of
code instead of 200 that has ten
features instead of five that has zero
bugs instead of twenty and be you know
ten twenty times as productive and so I
think that's where the disconnect begins
to happen with productivity is when
somebody goes from doing assembly line
type work that's simple and repetitive
to work that's more complex and mental
so III I think you know when that
Factory mindset it's all about that
efficiency work hard hard hard faster
faster faster but when we do this
knowledge work for a living but then
then all these other ingredients become
so important our focus in addition to
how well we manage our time super
interesting we've been speaking with
Chris Bailey author of two books about
productivity published in 13 languages
hyper focus how to be more productive in
a world of distraction and the
productivity project Chris really great
time today thanks so much for having me
Matt Knight nice to be here